hag Gango LED Namibia both as president
and two-time prime minister before his
presidential election Gango was prime
minister from 1990 when Namibia gained
independence from South Africa until
2002 and he became the country's longest
serving prime minister when he again
took office between 2012 and
thank
you Gango was born in 1941 and began a
teaching career 20 years
later in the 1970s gengo left his
homeland to work with the United Nations
while Rising within the ranks of the
independence movement the Southwest
Africa people's organization or
swapel following his return home after
almost three decades he along with
others Spearhead an election campaign
that brought swapo to power much of gb's
work as president focused on African
organizations conflict resolution and
good governance across the continent but
his reputation was tainted by one of the
country's worst corruption scandals
known as fish rot Gango was accused in
2021 of instructing a government
official to divert funds from a
state-run fishing company to bribe
attendees at the 2017 swapo Electric
Congress to vote for him he denied the
allegations all these efforts are driven
by a clear National political will of
zero tolerance towards corruption under
gb's leadership his party lost its
two-thirds majority in the 2019 election
while swapo remains namibia's largest
party its popularity waned due to voter
anger over Rising unemployment and the
corruption scandal in 2014 gengo
revealed he had survived prostate cancer
10 years later a regular medical checkup
revealed another cancer
diagnosis but his health deteriorated
rapidly following treatment in the
United States and later at home gab is
survived by his wife Monica kondo and
three children from previous
marriages make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz